liberal cnn once again mocking america's
massive crime wave and claiming the
surge in violence
is totally being overblown
you get the sense that america's gone to
hell declining quality of life america
as a apocalyptic hell's yes there is a
crime problem but the way it's described
on fox you'd be afraid to leave your
house i kind of think of it as a
instagram filter brian you know you
start with a real image and then you
take the filter and you pump it up a
thousand percent and what you're left
with is is distorted it no longer
reflects a reality the goal of this kind
of coverage is to freak people out to
cause them to live in fear
cnn might be the only ones to find that
funny because 81 percent of voters are
extremely or very concerned about higher
crime rates in this latest fox news poll
carjackings are soaring by over 500
percent in major cities while 16 cities
hit record homicides in 2021. and in
baltimore homicides are now the leading
cause for unexpected childhood deaths
what do you think the strategy was
behind that segment greg i don't know
it's strange it's got to be gross to
work at cnn where all you do is you push
these elaborate hoaxes while denying
actual human suffering right they spent
years pushing this elaborate wrestling
hoax trying to scare people that the
republicans indeed republican is in
danger but yet they lack they literally
laugh about crime people ask me why do i
constantly point out how fat brian
stelter is how fat and bald and homely
he is and i and i always tell you that
no insult is worse than their ideas
as long as they mocked the black and
black crime and the death in the streets
which there is tape of don lemon and
chris cuomo laughing about it as long as
they believe that and got a pass on it
then everything
is on the table you can make fun of them
about anything right so they chose this
hill to die on while cops and civilians
are literally dying how can i wonder how
like security can
can work at cnn and have to like be
around these people i mean these are
actual crime deniers they help build the
anti-cop narrative for i don't know how
many years so so to answer your question
the ratings are dying the narrative is
is antithetical to what americans
believe this is not a network interested
in the american viewer anymore this is a
curated propaganda machine to put out um
segments to other areas whether it's
social media
to be retweeted that are specifically
anti-american views this is not a
network i don't know how they get
advertisers at this point it's so
embarrassing they have producers that
are being accused of alleged pedophilia
i mean how do they i think that's what
that's the other thing too is this is a
distraction because they're in such
sorry shape
yeah so they don't have anything to talk
about because it's not a lot of good
news are they just trying to put stuff
out there for controversy do you think
because that's just stupid it is weird
to program a segment just to try to get
back at the five
i mean that is a strange way to program
i would say that
the one thing about is matching the mood
right so um i
i do the morning show now 9 to 11 a.m so
i see a lot of the other morning network
shows and they are starting to lead with
the story of the day and guess what that
is it is crime and when it's being asked
about at the white house um and not just
by fox news the one thing i feel like
the white house does and the president
is not doing you you need to match the
moment
and the mood of the country and if
you're not then you're going to get
polls that show that only a third of the
country think that you care about the
issues they're focused on and that's
what those polls were showing last week
the other thing is is that if you look
at cnn's own polling
on immigration and crime and inflation
if
if the execs aren't sharing cnn's own
polling with cnn's media reporting team
they maybe should like break down that
wall because their own polling is
showing that it's a problem and i assume
that these guys work out in new york
city right that's where they work out of
they don't need the apartment did they
do they see the local news do they read
the post the daily news are they
absorbing any of the actual crime that's
happening
in their own neighborhoods do you think
you're coming up i'm looking at you
talking to you denial denial does not
wear well and as i listen to them
i can understand if you're trying to
make a point that crime um that some
numbers are down and some numbers are up
or trying to explain that maybe the way
this is being presented is being
interpreted wrong they didn't do that
they didn't say that crime is down here
or people are looking at this the wrong
way
it strikes me as a group of people and
this is not meant to to malign cnn as
much as those who were on who
literally tried to present the crime is
not somehow another bad thing where do
you live to your point are you are you
in a neighborhood where you don't go out
or there's nothing happening or you have
a security team around you that's one
thing but if you live in a neighborhood
which is most neighborhoods
unfortunately in new york city today
you're watching where you're going i
don't take the subway any longer i used
to take this away i'll take the subway
because i'm concerned about my safety i
won't go on i won't go near subway stop
with my kids because i don't want to be
confronted and have to try to defend or
do something that that that would put
them in danger or myself in danger so
those want to do
do stages like that or do presentations
like that have a reason for doing it if
your reason is to just get back at
someone or show or network you're not
serving the people who watch your
network and the people who are in danger
every day and every night and are
sitting for that matter across the
country many of them who are probably
watching that network yeah maybe some
gullible person is watching cnn and they
don't la de da they walk out they're not
looking around they do have to do a
public service well look look
here here's the thing the media is the
megaphone for the democrats all right so
the even though they know 81 of the
american public is concerned about crime
they want to tell you that it's not a
problem
and so it is been clearly it's been but
their naivete unless they're lying
hypocrites and you pick the whatever you
want is really is it's gain saved by the
fact that you've got five cops who've
already been shot in new york city and
we're still in january of this year
you've got kids an 11 month old girl who
got shot in the face you know kids go to
sleep in their own beds these days and
in their own homes in their own bedrooms
they end up getting shot in their own
beds i mean if these people can't see
what is going on in the inner city in
the gangs that are controlling the
streets if they can't see what's going
on in the subways where women are being
openly raped and all of that horror or
horrific stuff that's going on well then
you know what they're they're just
stupid you're stupid it's elitist it's
elitist is what it is it's a it's
elitist is what it is do you remember
stelter was mad once because they
removed one a trash can outside of his
apartment do you remember that that was
his like oh my god that was the crime
for him is there wasn't a place to throw
away the twinkie wrapper oh greg
it's so mean hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else